هذا هو الأمر الذي يصعب عليك التفكير
فيه
لأنني إذا عشت في مدينة تم
قصفها بهذه الطريقة ، فمن المحتمل أن
أهرب ، فأنا لست شجاعًا ولكن
سكان هاركيف باقون ، فهذه مدينة
يبلغ عدد سكانها حوالي 1.5 مليون  يقدرون أن ما
يصل إلى مليون شخص
لا يزالون هنا الآن ، ومن الواضح أنه ليس لدينا
طريقة للتحقق من
هذا الرقم ، لكنك بالتأكيد لا تزال
ترى أن الناس هنا حتى في
المناطق الأكثر تضررًا هناك مكان في
الضواحي الشمالية الشرقية يسمى
سالتيفيكا  قضينا بعض الوقت خلال
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع في قصف شديد الخطورة لا هوادة
فيها ، لا يزال هناك أشخاص
يعيشون في تلك الشقق
ويعيشون ويبقون لأسباب مختلفة بالنسبة
للبعض ، إنها عملية مقاومة ، إنها
طريقة لإظهار التحدي
للآخرين ، إنها مسألة
كبار السن.  ليس لديهم بالضرورة أي
مكان يذهبون إليه
وأنا أتساءل عما إذا كان بإمكاننا القدوم
إلى هنا لمحاولة إلقاء نظرة على
حجم
الحفرة التي توجد بالخارج
كثيرًا جدًا  من الناس لا يريدون
ترك بريانا ، فهم يريدون أن
يظلوا الشيء المثير للاهتمام عندما
تتجول في الشوارع على الرغم من أن
ما لا تراه ترى بعض
الأشخاص هنا هو نوع من المدخل الكبير
إذا كنت  سوف
إلى هذا المبنى ولكنك لا ترى الكثير
من الأطفال ،
لا يزال هناك أطفال في المدينة
ولكن الغالبية العظمى منهم يعيشون
تحت الأرض في الوقت الحالي في محطة المترو ،
لذلك
كان هذا هنا نوعًا من المدخل
الكبير لذلك المبنى.
يمكن أن ترى بعض العمال قد
أوقفوا شاحنة هنا ،
فهم يحاولون نوعًا ما
إزالة بعض الأشياء الثمينة ،
لكن مرة أخرى يمكنك فقط رؤية
حجم
الضرر ، والدمار ، هناك حفرة ضخمة
خلف تلك الشاحنة البيضاء التي يمكنك
لن تلقي نظرة جيدة
من هذه الزاوية ، ولكن أيضًا المبنى الذي
خلفك يمكن أن ترى واجهته
ممزقة بشكل أساسي ولذا فمن
المدهش بصراحة
أن تعتقد أن أي شخص
لديه ما يكفي من الشجاعة للبقاء هنا